STOMACH MUELLER.
HE IS NOW VIEWED UNFAVORABLY UP
BY A RECORD 24% OF DEMOCRATS AND
A RECORD 33% OF INDEPENDENTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRITING
HIGHER THAN EVER BEFORE IN
SUPPORT FOR THE MUELLER IS
SLIDING.
IMAGINE IF THE PRESS WAS
ACTUALLY FAIR ABOUT THIS.
SO HERE'S THE QUESTION.
IS THE TIME RIGHT FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO VOLUNTARILY SUBMIT
TO AN INTERVIEW WITH MUELLER TO
GET THIS THING WRAPPED UP?
WHO BETTER TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THEN THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYER HIMSELF.
RUDY GIULIANI, HOW ARE YOU.
THE PRESIDENT LOOKS GREAT AND
SINGAPORE, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
OF COURSE, IT COMES BACK AND,
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> I CHECKED INTO THIS, AND WE
ARE VERY COMFORTABLE IF HE
COOPERATES, AND, INCLUDING THE
THINGS THAT ROSENSTEIN SAID TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF, THAT HE
IS NOT INVOLVED IN THAT
INVESTIGATION.
MY CONCERN IS THAT THE MOLAR
INVESTIGATION IS GOING ON
INTERMINABLY, AND I THINK IT IS
REFLECTED IN PUBLIC OPINION.
PUBLIC OPINION IS DISCUSSED, I
BET HE'S WASTED $20 MILLION.
MAYBE HE SHOULD PUT IN AN
INTERIM REPORT AND TELL US WHAT
HE'S GOT ON COLLUSION.
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, THE
PRESIDENT CAN FIRE ANYBODY HE
WANTS FOR ANY REASON HE WANTS.
THEY CAN'T EVEN INQUIRE ABOUT
THAT.
HE'S HARASSING MICHAEL COHEN,
AND THE PAUL MANAFORT CASE SEEMS
TO BE FALLING APART.
YOU TAKE THAT OUT AND, SECOND,
YOU HAVE THE RUSSIANS.
THEY ARE ALL IN RUSSIA, AND IT'S
A PHONY INDICTMENT.
THEY WERE HARASSING HILARY
RALLIES DRESSED UP LIKE CLOWNS,
WE HAD WORSE THAN THAT.
>> HAVE YOU ASKED FOR SPECIAL
COUNSEL OFFICE WHY THEY HAVEN'T
BROUGHT CERTAIN PEOPLE IN FOR
QUESTIONING?
I MEAN IF THEY WERE GOING TO
FOCUS ON THIS TRUMP TOWER
MEETING, AS WE KNOW, THAT'S PART
OF THE FOCUSED.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY BRING IN THE
RUSSIAN ATTORNEY THAT MAKES THIS
BIG PITCH, IT'S CLOSE TO PUTIN.
WELL, SHE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
COME, AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE PULLED UP VERY EARLY
ABOUT THIS.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T BE INDICTED,
THE SITTING PRESIDENT CAN'T BE
INDICTED, NO ONE DISPUTES THAT.
AND HE'S NOT.
SO HE GETS TO WRITE THE REPORT.
JUST TO GET IT OVER WITH.
HE'S GOTTEN 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS, 32 WITNESSES, WE
RAISED NO EXECUTIVE, AND HE'S
GOT THE MATERIAL FROM WHICH TO
WRITE A REPORT RIGHT NOW.
EXCEPT THE REPORT WOULD SAY NO
EVIDENCE IN COLLUSION.
>> HE WANTS TO GET IN THE STATE
OF MIND.
IT'S THE STATE OF MIND QUESTION.
>> I THINK HE -- HE CAN'T DO
THAT UNTIL HE GETS THE PRESIDENT
ACROSS THE TABLE.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
HIS WHOLE THEORY IS COCKAMAMIE.
I CAN INTERPRET, PLUS AN ARTICLE
TO IMMUNITY, AND I THINK HE DID
IT FOR A CORRUPT REASON.
SO I'M GOING TO RECOMMEND THAT
HE DID SOMETHING WRONG.
PLUS HIS MAIN WITNESS THERE IS
COMEY.
AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
HOROWITZ REPORT IN DETAIL, BUT I
THINK IT WILL BE A TOUGH ONE,
IT'S 500 PAGES.
>> Laura: AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS SEEN IT?
>> TOMORROW AT THREE OR FOUR, HE
GETS AN UNEDITED VERSION OF IT,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
JUICY STUFF WILL BE.
BUT, AT A MINIMUM, WE KNOW WE
ARE CRITICIZING HIM HEAVILY FOR
HIS FIRST HILLARY PRESS
CONFERENCE AND HIS SECOND
HILLARY PRESS CONFERENCE.
HE STARTS THE RESPONSIBILITY,
AND HE BECAME THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI,
AND THE CHIEF DETECTIVE DECIDED
WHETHER TO PROSECUTE THAT.
HE WROTE THE REPORT TWO MONTHS
BEFORE.
HOW ABOUT WRITING THE REPORT
NOW?
HE SAID, THAT WOULD BE AN
IMPROPER INVESTIGATION.
>> WHEN DO YOU DETERMINED THE
ISSUE OF WRITTEN ANSWERS?
>> WE ARE ADDRESSING THAT NOW
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WE ARE ALL WORKING ON THAT, IS
THERE A DISPUTE AMONG YOU ABOUT
HOW TO PROCEED?
I MEAN THAT'S HEALTHY.
>> ALL OF US KNOW HE SHOULDN'T
TESTIFY UNLESS WE GET EVERYTHING
WE WANT AND HE WANTS.
YOU KNOW HIM, HE WANTS TO
TESTIFY.
'S COMPLAINT IS, I DID NOTHING
WRONG AND I CAN STAND UP TO ANY
QUESTIONING.
BUT THEY ARE REALLY GOOD
LAWYERS.
>> THEY ARE ALSO DISREPUTABLE
AND UNETHICAL LAWYERS.
WHAT ABOUT THE ONES THAT HAVE
BEEN CITED FOR UNETHICAL
VIOLATIONS?
DO YOU THINK I'M GOING TO TRUST
HIM WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT WHO
WOULD DO THE QUESTIONING?
>> I THINK IT SHOULD BE MUELLER.
WHEN I -- KEN WAS AN APPELLATE
LAWYER, I WAS A TRIAL LAWYER.
AND HE WAS A TRIAL LAWYER SO
IT'S HIS REPUTATION AT STAKE.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GUYS WORRIED
THAT THERE ARE ANY TAPE
RECORDINGS THAT MICHAEL COHEN
MIGHT HAVE IN HIS POSSESSION OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CONSENT
EITHER HE COULD HAVE EXAGGERATED
THINGS TO OTHER PEOPLE TO LIKE
CURRY FAVOR OR LOOK LIKE HE'S
BIGGER THAN HE IS?
I'M NOT SAYING HE DID THAT.
BUT YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW, YOU
HAVE SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS BUT
NOT ALL THE DOCUMENTS THAT WAS
TURNED OVER TO THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK, THAT THEY
SEIZED.
SO YOU ARE LOOKING AT THEM FOR
PRIVILEGED.
JUST LIKE HE'S DONE NOTHING
WRONG IN THIS THING, HE WAS
CLEAN AS A WHISTLE.
HE MIGHT HAVE BEEN TOUGH, MIGHT
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT ON
SITUATIONS, BUT HE WAS A MAN OF
HIS WORD.
MICHAEL: I THINK WOULD TELL YOU
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED    I
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED    C
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED    A
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED    I
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED    G
HE HAS NOTHING INCRIMINATED    .
YOU ARE A FORMER PROSECUTOR,
THEY THREATENED TO BANKRUPT YOU
AND ITS HIGH BILLS, THEY PILE UP
REAL FAST.
YOU GO TO JAIL FOR TEN YEARS.
>> THE REALITY IS THEY ARE
TRYING TO FRIGHTEN HIM.
MICHAEL IS A TOUGH GUY, I DON'T
THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN.
AND IF HE DOES, BUT DON'T THINK
HE'S GOING TO LIE.
>> INNOCENT PEOPLE DON'T WORRY
ABOUT WHETHER SOMEONE WILL FLIP
ON THEM, AND LET'S BE HONEST,
PRESIDENTS DON'T HAVE FIXERS.
I THINK WE ARE SO IN THE THINK
OF THIS THAT WE TAKE A STEP BACK
AND WE REALIZE THAT EVERY DAY,
TALK ABOUT MR. COHEN WHO IS
DONALD TRUMP'S FIXER.
INNOCENT PEOPLE FIX THINGS BY
SHOOTING STRAIGHT AND TELLING
THE TRUTH, SO I THINK THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF A DARK, DARK
STONE.
STORM.
>> FIXER MEAN SOMEONE WHO CAN
GET THINGS DONE, PEOPLE HIRE
THEM IN NEW YORK, THEY ARE
CALLED EXPEDITERS.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T KNOW
NEW YORK LINGO.
>> WHAT HE MEANT BY THAT WAS, I
EXPEDITED THINGS, I GOT THEM
DONE.
NOT ILLEGALLY.
NO ONE HAS EVER SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT UNTIL NOW.
THIS IDEA THAT A PRESIDENT WHO
NOTHING WRONG ISN'T GOING TO BE
FRAMED BY SOMEBODY.
WHEN THEY DONATED 36 GRANTED TO
HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN OR, AT HER
VICTORY/TO DEFEAT PARTY, THEY
CRIED THE NIGHT SHE LOST.
THESE GUYS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CITED FOR NOT TURNING OVER IN IT
EVIDENCE ABOUT INNOCENT PEOPLE
AND AT THIS IDIOT CONGRESSMAN
WANTS ME TO TRUST HIM?
I'VE BEEN A LAWYER FOR A LONG
TIME, THAT KATE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: ARE YOU ALSO GOING
TO MAKE AN ARGUMENT ABOUT THE
UNDERLYING CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THIS
PROCESS?
>> BOTH ON HIS FACE AND AS
APPLIED TO.
BECAUSE ON ITS FACE, THE STATUTE
ITSELF, AND SECOND, THE FACT
THAT IT WAS PRODUCED BY WHAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A TOTALLY
ILLEGAL COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION THAT THEY TRIED TO
MAKE INTO A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
AND CLEARLY BY THE COMEY MEMO,
WE HAVE TO SEE WHAT HOROWITZ
SAYS TOMORROW.
>> Laura: KELLYANNE CONWAY'S
HUSBAND, GEORGE, I'VE KNOWN HIM
FOR MANY YEARS.
HE'S BRILLIANT, WE THOUGHT HE
MIGHT BE SG AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, HE WOULD HAVE MADE A
GREAT ONE.
HE HAS WRITTEN AN ARTICLE FOR
THE HILL THAT HE BASICALLY SAYS,
THIS ARGUMENT ABOUT THE
UNCONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE
STATUTE, HE JUST SMASHES
CALABRESE'S ARGUMENT.
HE BUYS INTO THE APPOINTMENTS
CLAUSE OUT ARGUMENT HERE, AND HE
JUST DESTROYS THAT.
IS THERE ANY CONCERN ABOUT THAT
AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> NO CONCERN ABOUT IT.
FEELING YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE
ON EVERYTHING.
[LAUGHS]
>> METHODS CLEAR OF AN ARGUMENT
AS LET'S SAY THEIR ABILITY TO
INDICT, OR EVEN THEIR ABILITY TO
SUBPOENA, AS IT IS TRUE IN
ARTICLE TWO.
>> Laura: HAVE YOU WRITTEN A
BRIEF ON THAT?
>> MORE OR LESS.
HOWEVER, I WOULD THINK, MAYBE HE
WANTS HIM OUT OF SUPREME COURT
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU WILL GET
THE APPOINTMENT.
>> Laura: I WAS LIKE, GEORGE
IS LIKE -- >> GEORGE IS NOT
GETTING ON THE SUPREME COURT, I
CAN PICK PREDICT THAT.
>> Laura: IS THEIR CONCERN
ABOUT -- LET'S GO BACK TO COHEN
FOR A MINUTE.
I'M NOT AS BIG OF A FAN OF
PROSECUTORS, BUT I'M NOT AS BIG
OF A FAN OF PROSECUTORS AS SOME
CONSERVATIVES ARE BECAUSE WITH
UNBRIDLED POWER AND UNCHECKED
POWER COMES ABUSE OF DISCRETION.
FROM PATRICK FITZGERALD, --
THERE ARE LIKE FOUR PEOPLE.
>> REPRESENTATIVE COMEY.
>> Laura: YES, SCOOTER LIBBY,
ALL THE REST OF IT.
SO WHEN SOMEONE LIKE HIM HAS THE
SCREWS TURNED ON HIM, YOU WILL
LOSE YOUR FAMILY, BE IN JAIL FOR
TEN YEARS, WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
GIVE US?
YOU ARE GOING TO TELL US.
PEOPLE FREAK OUT AND THAT'S WITH
THE POWER OF PROSECUTORS DO.
>> I EMPATHIZE GREATLY WITH
MICHAEL, I DON'T BELIEVE HE WILL
TELL A FALSEHOOD, I BELIEVE HE'S
GOING TO TELL THE TRUTH AND WE
ARE VERY COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
>> Laura: BUT WHAT IF HE IS IN
TROUBLE ON ANOTHER MATTER?
>> HE WILL DEAL WITH IT.
AND I THINK -- I STILL TRUST IN
HIM UNTIL THEY SHOW ME
SOMETHING, TO THE CONTRARY.
>> Laura: REPORTS ARE THAT HE
IS UPSET BECAUSE -- HE'S FEELING
ALL ALONE OUT THERE.
>> I BET IT FEELS THAT WAY, TOO.
BUT WE ADVISE THE PRESIDENT THAT
THAT WOULD BE MISUNDERSTOOD.
>> Laura: NOW, YOU CAN'T PICK
UP THE PHONE.
>> YOU TELL YOUR CLIENT OVER
TIME, DON'T TALK TO THIS PERSON.
PAUL MANAFORT WAS PROBABLY
TOTALLY INNOCENT BUT THEY TURNED
IT INTO ANOTHER CHARGE, BECAUSE
THE FIRST CHARGES GOING UNDER.
>> Laura: WHEN IS YOUR BEST
GUESS THAT THIS THING WILL BE
DECIDED WITHOUT THE TESTIMONY?
BECAUSE AT THAT.
THEY'VE INTERVIEWED PRETTY MUCH
EVERYONE THEY WANTED.
>> I BELIEVE WE WILL DECIDE
UNLESS SOMETHING GOES WRONG.
WITHOUT A COUPLE OF THINGS GO
WRONG, THE COHEN SITUATION, THE
SPYGATE TO THE SITUATION.
IF NOTHING ELSE BREAKS LIKE
THAT, POSSIBLY THIS HOROWITZ
THING.
IT'S 500 PAGES.
BUT WE SHOULD GIVE THE DECISION
DONE IN THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO,
WHICH MEANS THEN WE GO TO
BATTLING OVER A SUBPOENA OR
GETTING IT READY FOR A SMALL,
TAILORED, LIMITED INTERVIEW.
>> Laura: 150 SUBPOENAS, BLANK
SUBPOENAS.
THIS CAME OUT LATE TODAY.
MUELLER HAS REQUESTED THAT.
WHAT COULD THAT BE ABOUT?
IS THAT LIKE A MIND GAME?
>> FRANKLY, IF IT IS A MIND GAME
IT WORKS THE OPPOSITE WAY.
AT THIS LATE STAGE, IF YOU STOP
ISSUING 150 SUBPOENAS, HE'S GOT
NOTHING.
>> Laura: WHAT HAVE THEY BEEN
DOING FOR THE LAST YEAR?
>> WHERE IS THE COLLISION, WHERE
IS THE OBSTRUCTION, EXCEPT IN
THEIR HEAD.
IF THEY HAVE TO DO 150 SUBPOENAS
AT THIS POINT, AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS THIS, THEY HAVE NO CASE
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU TALKED TO
COHEN A YEAR AGO, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'VE HEARD WHEN HE WAS
GOING TO TRY TO GET THAT
TRUMP TOWER IN MOSCOW DONE.
HE WANTED TO GET THAT DONE AND
HAD REPORTEDLY WRITTEN A NOTE TO
POLLUTANT SAME, THIS IS A LOGJAM
HERE, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN, IT
DIDN'T GO ANYWHERE.
BUT THAT IS ALWAYS LISTED IN THE
ONE OR TWO OR THREE RUSSIAN
INTEREST CONTACTS THAT COHEN
MADE.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THIS, HAVE YOU
BEEN DISCUSSING IT?
>> WE ARE AWARE AND WE THINK IT
HAS NO CONNECTION.
>> Laura: WAS A GREEN LIGHTED
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT, THAT
WOULD BE COMPETENCE, BUT THE
REALITY IS, NOTHING CAME OF IT.
THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO FOR
IT.
IN ESSENCE, IF THE PRESIDENT HAD
COLLUDED, WHICH HE DIDN'T -- THE
PRESIDENT WILL TELL YOU IN THE
TWO YEARS AFTER THE ELECTION, I
JUST DIDN'T TALK TO ANY
RUSSIANS, I DON'T KNOW ANY
RUSSIANS.
>> Laura: HE DIDN'T DRINK, SO
YOU KNOW HE DIDN'T ORDER A WHITE
RUSSIAN.
>> HE DOESN'T DRINK AT ALL.
THEY WERE BITTER OVER LOSING THE
ELECTION AND SOME RIGHT IN
MULLER'S OFFICE WERE THE ONES
CRYING LIKE BABIES THE NIGHT
THAT HILLARY LOST.
IF THEY ARE TRYING TO
DELEGITIMATIZE HIM.
WE WANT THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
REGRETS NOT HAVING A BETTER
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA BECAUSE
OF ALL OF THIS.
>> THAT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY
COLLATERAL DAMAGE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THANK GOD HE WAS ABLE TO DO